anoche fue otra jornada donde sonaron
las alarmas no solamente una sino en dos
ocasiones tanto en kiev como en el resto
del país aún así hoy ha salido el sol en
la capital y la gente se ha tirado a las
calles especialmente aquí en la
cercanías del río nieper y aprovechando
que hoy es el Día de la madre que es un
día precioso de Primavera sin embargo
también resuenan lo sucedido anoche
durante esas alarmas donde volvieron a
lanzarse ataques con drones kamikasis y
con misiles especialmente en el oeste
del país en tecnópolis donde era
originario el grupo que anoche
representaba a Ucrania en ese concurso
de eurovisión recordemos que Ucrania lo
había ganado el año pasado y le
correspondía hacerlo en el país pero por
consecuencias de la guerra se hizo esta
vez en Liverpool y en el momento en el
que el grupo que representaba el país
estaba actuando los rusos volvían a
atacar especialmente en la ciudad donde
estos jóvenes eran originarios Ellos
dicen desde Moscú que atacaban un
almacén Donde había armas y municiones
dadas por accidente esto no ha sido
confirmado por Ucrania lo que sí se
conoce es lo que está sucediendo en
bakmuth donde siguen esos
enfrentamientos A los alrededores de la
ciudad el instituto de estudios de la
guerra con sede Washington que monitorea
la guerra en Ucrania y que todos los
días da un informe sobre lo que sucede
en el terreno hablaba De que al menos
16.5 kilómetros cuadrados han sido
recuperados por Ucrania en los últimos
días las situaciones diferentes dentro
de la ciudad donde los rusos siguen
teniendo el control de la mayoría de las
calles siguen las peleas y siguen los
ataques han circulado bastantes vídeos
donde se ven nuevos ataques con bombas
incendiarias en bacmut sin embargo
también quedan evidencias a División
entre esas fuerzas Wagner que pelean en
el centro de la ciudad con el ejército
ruso siguen habiendo divisiones según lo
comentaba en uno de sus videos el
fundador y el dueño de estas fuerzas
paramilitares
y también queda en evidencia esos
ataques que se vienen dando a diferentes
regiones tanto en Ucrania como en
territorio controlado ocupado por ellos
especialmente en Luján lo que hace
pensar a muchos que la contraofensiva o
que se planea para los próximos días
está comenzando